hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and Marvel has
surprised us with the first teaser
trailer of Thor Ragnarok and for real I
am super hyped for this movie it looks
like Marvel is pivoting from Thor the
dark world to tell a more colorful
cosmic adventure in the vein of
guardians of the galaxy and really what
readers of the Thor comics always loved
and I think another big reason why this
trailers so fun is that it includes a
ton of little Winx and Easter eggs that
remind us of other exciting superhero
movie moments so in this video I'm gonna
break down all of that along with some
theories and predictions and I'm gonna
go super in-depth frame-by-frame leaving
no infinity stone unturned and yeah I
said stone not Jim from the comics
because Jim doesn't really work with the
expression anyways shut up let's get
started
well I know what you're thinking
out of this heaven so the trailer opens
with Thor chained up lowered into this
deep lava cavern Temple of Doom style in
right away the trailer does this kind of
jokey paws on him with this meta
narration well I know what you're
thinking
how did this happen and this is
interesting because it's not very common
to see a superhero narrate his own movie
like this in fact this moment kind of
reminds me of that scene in Deadpool
where he also similarly explained to the
audience how he ended up so horizontal I
think we can all agree that [ __ ] just
went sideways in the most colossal way
but this isn't the first time this has
happened in the MCU either remember Iron
Man 3 began with a similar voiceover
from Tony Stark a famous man once said
we create our own demons I don't I'm
gonna start again and sure I don't know
if Thor's line here was recorded just
for the trailer or if this line comes
later in the scene with like Hulk or
Valkyrie or Loki or if it's all part of
a framing device the way it was an Iron
Man 3 with Bruce Banner in that
post-credit scene like maybe this time
it'll be Thor baring his soul putting
Bruce to sleep or maybe it'll be Tony
not Enoch we'll see either way since
this is the third Thor movie I think
this narration a lot of other stuff in
this trailer just wants to echo the
third Iron Man movie also where is this
place it's dark and fiery and those
glowing rocks look kind of like faces
like they could be the faces of the
Damned
so this is most likely hell and Norse
mythology hell is the opposite of
Valhalla in Asgard and in the comics
it's ruled over by hella the goddess of
death Cate Blanchett in this movie who
looks awesome in this trailer so hella
is confined to her own world ruling over
the dead but she wants to expand her
rule over the dead in Valhalla as well
and in this shot it looks like she's
breaking free from her world we can see
her torn clothes as she walks through
the rift in space and let's move on to
the second part of this shot
it's a long story
[Music]
okay so huge moment here hella freakin
catches Thor's hammer Mjolnir and she
destroys it
so this surprise catch reminds me of
that trailer moment in Captain America's
Civil War when the Winter Soldier
catches cap shield no one is supposed to
be able to do that so yeah it's a big
deal for Thor to lose his hammer and I'm
guessing that this happens early in the
movie because we never really see mill
near on him in any other shots and I
think that this is another detail that
connects Thor to the other Avengers
remember both the third Iron Man and the
third Captain America movies both
separated the heroes from their iconic
weapons
Tony blew up all of his gear and chucked
his arc reactor and cab left his scratch
shield behind him at the end of Civil
War
and sure Tony just sended up making new
armor and I'm certain that we'll see cap
with the shield again and I'm predicting
that Thor will in this movie with some
version of his hammer maybe a new one
modeled on the ultimate Thor comics like
we saw in the infinity war concept art
but I think these Avengers losing their
toys is an important lesson to learn
like what Tony told Peter Parker in the
recent spider-man homecoming trailer but
nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this shoot then you
shouldn't have it now it's looking like
this movie will also reveal the six the
final Infinity stone after the time
stone was revealed and Doctor Strange
that just leaves the soul stone and some
people had a theory that the sole stone
was inside Mjolnir since it's kind of a
magical instrument and only the vision
could lift it maybe because he has the
mind stone on his forehead now I don't
see an infinity stone anywhere in these
shards maybe hella grabbed it already or
maybe it's somewhere else but more on
that later also this fight looks like
it's happening in an urban location
maybe New York and we know from set
photos and the Doctor Strange
post-credits scene that Thor is going to
be visiting Doctor Strange at his
sanctum sanctorum in New York City
looking for his brother Loki and it's
Potter Odin and if you look really
closely at this wide shot you can see
Loki width or in this alley this scene
was actually depicted in the concept art
so I'm guessing that Thor found his
brother in New York but hella caught up
to them or Loki might have arranged this
to trap Thor but I have other thoughts
in that theory later on and real quick I
just want to point out the look of this
Marvel Studios title card
notice how it flies out at us that's
similar to the titles in the guardians
of the galaxy volume two trailers James
Gunn who directs those movies actually
tweeted that this trailer for Thor
Ragnarok might be the best Marvel
Studios trailer ever even besting his
own trailers but honestly considering
that Thor seems to be using a similar
vibrant visual style to the guardians
movies Gunn's approval seems a bit more
like excitement over his own positive
influence on the MCU all right moving on
[Music]
so in this section we hear this awesome
music
it's immigrant song by Led Zeppelin and
I honestly don't know how this song
wasn't already used for a Thor movie
it's kind of the perfect rock anthem for
Norse God the lyrics are all about
Vikings dreaming of war and conquest
with lines like hammer of the gods and
b'hala I am coming but the song also
works in context for hella who rules
over hell and Niflheim which is a realm
of primordial ice and cold or as Led
Zeppelin puts it and like the speaker in
the song hella is kind of an immigrant
invading this new land in order to
conquer it and let's talk about hella
here she looks fierce with this insane
antler headgear almost identical to Jack
Kirby's original design and the Marvel
Comics and the composition of the shot
with the angles of her antlers
contrasting sharply with the background
makes Hello looks so sinister and I just
love the top if I put into the
photography of this movie we also see
hella as she arrives in Asgard and
proclaims it dead so this is connected
to the title of the movie Ragnarok in
the early Earth or comics Ragnarok
referred to the end of the universe in
Norse mythology the destruction of Ajala
and the death of all the gods it's
actually part of a cycle that repeats
over and over with Asgard being reborn
afterward and lasting until the next
Ragnarok occurs now this isn't to be
confused with the character Ragnarok
that was a cyborg clone of Thor from the
Marvel civil war comics run and that's
not really part of this movie so this is
the event Ragnarok and while it was
something that we did see in the comics
Thor actually found a way to end that
cycle
hello's assault here comes from a
different part of the comics when she
conspires with Loki to try to bring
about Ragnarok but she fails actually
interesting thing about that comic or
has to fight without his hammer just
like he does in this movie and this
version of hella gets a lot closer to
full Ragnarok torching Asgard in this
wall of fire now I'm not sure if this
close up of Thor in the fire is from
this battle exactly or if it's back in
New York but this is pre haircut so I'm
guessing it's early in the film before
he's exiled to Sekar which we see in
this shot as the
flies out of a portal so just to recap
what I see is the timeline of these
shots Thor starts out in New York with
dr. strange and then he finds Loki and
then gets jumped by hella who chains him
up and banishes him to Sekar leaving
Asgard more open to attack and if that's
a case it really only seems to cover the
first part of the movie so there's so
much about the story that we still don't
know which is kind of great all right
let's move on
so here we see Thor on the planets a car
which is this scrap covered planet that
loves gladiatorial combat and yes this
is all from the planet Holt comics which
I'll talk about later but this idea of
Thor getting taken in as a warrior slave
seems like it's borrowing from movies
like Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome which
like Thor Ragnarok was the third
installment of its series and it was
about a warrior who ends up in his
shitty place forced to fight as a
gladiator the character even goes from
long hair to short hair and this person
kidnapping Thor is Valkyrie and she's
played by Tessa Thompson Valkyrie is a
major character from the Thor comics
she's also known as Brunhilde she leads
the Valkyrie or which is a group of
female warriors who guides the souls of
slain heroes back to Valhalla but in
this movie Valkyrie has ended up on
Sekar gathering fighters for this
gladiator combat and these other shots
might explain why Valkyrie left her old
job you can see her here with her iconic
blue cape from the comics writing her
winged horse Aragorn
with the other Valkyrie or leading an
assault on hella in hell and this looks
like it could be part of that same
sequence as that shot of hello that we
saw before and after hella tosses her
sword there's this quick shot showing
Valkyrie and her warriors falling to the
ground so I'm guessing that this was
part of a flashback battle scene showing
how this humiliating defeat led to her
exile to sack are like now she's using
her warriors seeking skills to bring
back these poor souls to fight to
entertain the masses and as Thor gets
dragged in to get this involuntary
haircut you can see what looks like some
other gladiators training and this guy
is a trident some people are saying that
that could be a reference to Namor who
carries a trident of Neptune or you know
it's just a warrior with a trident you
guys tridents are actually pretty great
melee weapons and before I move on
there's this shot of Valkyrie as she
turns away from Thor no little guilty
and she's carrying what looks like four
packets all boys or something maybe
that's her bounty for bringing in Thor
but this look of guilt implies that she
still cares about her fellow Asgardian
maybe that means that she'll be
instrumental and
helping him and Hulk escape let's move
on what have you brought today tell me
so this section introduces us to Jeff
Goldblum as the Grandmaster he's the
ruler of Sekar who arranges all these
gladiator matches in his Coliseum and
check out these big furry things
shimmying on either side of Thor's so
what the hell are these and my first
stupid thought was that these are just
both the legs of a giant dancing whomp
up from Empire Strikes Back like this
knee owns both the Marvel and Star Wars
universes so anything can happen but
really these are probably just some
goofy looking dancers on the grand
master suite and if you look closely at
the background there are these red and
blue figures on each side and this whole
shot is symmetrical and based on Thor's
confused expression here I'm wondering
if he's under the influence of some drug
that's causing him to trip balls it
would explain why he was so lethargic
and passive as they dragged him in for
that haircut but really these bright
colors and goofy visuals are another
element that makes thor ragnarok
feel more true to the cosmic adventurous
spirit of the Thor comics and part of
that same colorful Marvel phase 3 that
the guardians of the galaxy movie
belongs to and I think that's
intentional because in the comics the
Grandmaster is one of the ageless elders
of the universe along with the collector
whom we saw in guardians and I think
that the relationship between these two
characters is how Thor Ragnarok will tie
in to the events of the upcoming
infinity Wars movies we also see this
shot of Heimdall fighting trading in his
helmet for some awesome dreads now I
mentioned this before in a video that I
did on Doctor Strange but one popular
theory is that Heimdall possesses the
sixth Infinity stone the soul stone now
people think that this is partly because
his name begins with an H and the
locations of the other stones kind of
spell out to the name Thanos
anyway that's kind of a stretch and I'm
not totally buying it but I do think
that there definitely is something to
Heimdall's ability to see Souls wherever
they are in the universe and the orange
glow in his eyes which might be
connected to the soul stone which is
supposed to have an orange color and
some people have pointed to this round
looking piece on its chest plate as
possibly the soul stone we'll see we
also get our first look at Karl Urban as
scourge the executioner now there
an interesting miscible detail about
this shot of him that I'm gonna point
out but first quickly I want to say that
we love going super in-depth with all
this Marvel stuff and part of the reason
that I'm able to do that is by keeping
up with all the Marvel information using
audible now audible offers a wide
selection of audiobooks and you can get
a free audiobook with a 30-day trial at
audible.com slash new rock stars there's
actually one audio book that had just
finished called Marvel Comics the untold
story by Sean Haugh it's about how
marble comics evolved to dominate so
much of our culture and it explains a
lot of why these movies are the way they
are now audible is great for when you're
commuting or working out or when you're
getting a haircut and you're just too
awkward to make small talk doors with me
so you can turn your commute or your
awkward social interactions into
something more with a free trial at
audible.com slash new rockstars to start
now okay back to scourge so in the
comics scourge is kind of an anti
villain like he's kind of slow and he
always loses and his fights against Thor
but scourge is also known for wielding a
double bladed blood axe and here he's
firing two in six teens this could be a
reference to one of the coolest things
about this character but man being kind
of big spoilers so if you're worried
about that skip to this time so in Thor
issue 362 scourge is on a suicide
mission led by Thor into hell to rescue
mortal Souls held unjustly by Ella and
in order to escape they have to cross
this narrow bridge called Pilar brew
separating the two worlds and it
climaxes with this dramatic Redemption
scene of scourge firing mm6 teens to
hold the bridge sacrificing his life
while the others escape and the words he
stood alone a gala brew end up being
this powerful epitaph for the character
and I think this shot of scourge with
the machine guns looks at least like a
reference to this iconic moment okay
let's move on to this next section
it's main event time
[Music]
[Applause]
so here we get one shot that looks like
it could be part of Thor's and hoax
escape from Sekar and another look at
hella embattled Asgard now wearing the
antler headgear probably just seconds
away from stabbing someone with it come
on you could have shown us that but we
also get this mysterious shot of Loki as
he flips his daggers now we still don't
really know for sure what Loki's up to
in this movie but my best guess is that
he was somehow instrumental in releasing
hella from hell remember at the end of
the dark world
Loki was impersonating Odin I think that
he might have been able to use that
stolen authority to unleash her on
Asgard and to bring about Ragnarok so
let's look at this shot a bit more
closely that looks like a bridge maybe
gala brew the bridge between worlds that
I talked about before and that mountain
this passage behind him could lead to
the rocky terrain of Hell that we saw in
the other shots also there's this mob of
people trying to push through these
might be souls of people trapped in Hell
trying to break free hopefully future
trailers will give us a few more angles
on this to make some sense of it and
these next shots bring us to the main
event of this trailer the Coliseum wants
a car with these green smoke effects
probably to celebrate the green crowd
favorite and Thor enters the arena
looking very much to me like Maximus
from gladiator with this shorter hair
and yeah I kind of want to see him throw
that just pull into the audience and
scream like oh you're not entertained
and I'm really digging Thor's helmet
design here it kind of addresses the
issue that's bugged a lot of fans about
the Thor movies the fact that the movie
Thor never really wears the helmet from
the comics and to be honest that was
never really an issue with me like I
never really cared for the wings on his
helmet but this helmet with the
adjustable chin guards gives Thor's head
that classic shape while remaining
practical it actually kind of reminds me
of Catwoman and The Dark Knight Rises
how her goggles flipped up to look like
the classic cat ears no no kind of cool
but let's move on to this final awesome
clip
we know each other he's a friend from
work seriously it's like Marvel read all
of our minds and knew exactly what kind
of movie we wanted this to be everything
about this is just perfect
first notice those shield here red and
white stripes blue inner circle it kind
of seems like he picked that out because
it reminded him of cap shields also it's
so great to hear the Grandmaster
introduced the Hulk this way
and I'm really liking how Marvel is
using these heroes comic-book
descriptions in the trailers can't you
just be a friendly neighborhood
spider-man and yeah hope just looks
fantastic here the CGI is really well
rendered and notices armor this is
clearly taken from the Planet Hulk comic
storyline so a quick reminder in the
comics Hulk goes on a rampage that
destroys most of Las Vegas so Nick Fury
sends him on a space mission where he
ends up on Sekar fighting as this
popular gladiator warrior so neither
Hulk north or were present for the
Marvel Civil War event which is also one
of the reasons why they were left out of
the Civil War movie but now it seems
like the plan is to bring Thor into this
Planet Hulk storyline which I think is
brilliant because not only we we get to
see an awesome rematch from the Avengers
will also probably get to see them work
together as old work friends probably
breaking free Thor's reaction here
reminds me a lot of Drax is huge laughs
in the Guardians trailers it's basically
what we are all feeling in this moment
and judging from the reaction of the
crowd and the Grandmaster and even match
is less preferable to Hulk just smashing
someone's brains in also it's
interesting that Loki is joining the
Grandmaster here in these very Jack
Kirby inspired box seats again it seems
like Loki is playing a more nefarious
role as if he's come to see his brother
suffer and maybe die but judging from
Loki's nervous glance to the Grandmaster
he is
probably remembering the last time he
ran into hold
and I think this snide shot of the two
friends charging at each other which by
the way I think the words gonna get the
first hit with that uppercut all this is
meant to evoke another shot that ended a
recent Marvel trailer so now we see what
Hulk and Thor were doing while the rest
of their friends were in a civil war
they were in the middle of their own
okay that's everything that I caught in
this trailer and let me know what you
think in the comments what do you think
Loki's plan will be where do you think
the soulstone is and how will Doctor
Strange play into this story like I know
the sorcerer supreme is in this movie
too and I was too overwhelmed but if you
like this video please hit like and
subscribe to new rock stars we cover all
kinds of Marvel stuff all super in-depth
like this so take a look around
and if you really like this channel you
can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our current patrons you
guys are awesome especially Kelly done
you can hit me up on Twitter at EA boss
with any thoughts or theories you have
about Thor Ragnarok or Paul the new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars for
updates on our videos alright thanks for
watching bye